Hawking radiation is probably a thing no
it doesn't break the rules by escaping
the outer edge of a black hole is
defined by its Event Horizon nothing
inside can escape because all Futures
Point inward black holes don't trap
things they trap the future
Hawking radiation is emitted by the
space-time around a black hole as in
outside the Event Horizon it's generated
outside a black hole quite a ways
outside actually what makes it such a
big deal is that it allows black holes
to shrink over time it won't happen for
a long long time like longer than you
can possibly imagine
but in the very distant future all black
holes will evaporate releasing all their
energy back into the universe that stuff
won't look anything like the stuff that
fell in but at least energy is conserved